you  as a heart failure patient you may need  to make some lifestyle changes to  prevent further damage to your heart  if you smoke quitting is one of the most  important things you can do for your  heart  with your health care provider to create  a nutritious eating plan that also helps  you maintain a healthy weight a heart  healthy diet includes vegetables fruits  lean meats and whole grains as well as  low-fat or fat-free dairy products  reduce the amount of salt and sugar you  eat substitute solid fats with  heart-healthy oils  limit the amount of fluid you drink and  remember a heart-healthy diet doesn't  include alcohol also check with your  doctor about an exercise plan that's  right for you 30 minutes of daily  low-impact exercise can help to  strengthen your heart